what is up everybody it's animak here
for
anime uproar and today i will be
discussing the latest
mind-blowing events in the black clover
story
including the unveiling of a new
ultimate magic
power the escalation of the final
showdown
inside the spade kingdom and the
possible death
of an important member of the black
bulls
this story is just crazy right now so
let's get into it if you enjoy the black
clover content
on this channel and you want us to keep
it going please leave a like
and comment it helps me out a lot
and if you're new to anime opera or
maybe you watch our videos but you
haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
finally this video will of course
contain black clover manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution
you have been warned now in the previous
chapter
we witnessed that epic entrance that the
heart kingdom gang
made as they suddenly joined the spade
kingdom
infiltration mission the latest chapter
starts off with a flashback to elysia
and this flashback explains what
happened to the heart kingdom gang
right after we last saw them that divine
creature that patri had talked about
the guardian deity known as dryad turned
out to be a giant female
tree waifu i'm not sure if she's
supposed to be a fairy or
nymph or something else altogether but
whatever she is
dryad is very friendly and outgoing and
she has the ability to tell the future
at least to some limited extent i was
actually thinking that tree waifu might
be the fourth elemental
spirit the elemental spirit of the earth
but then again if she was
wouldn't patri have just said so the
existence of the elemental spirits is
common knowledge so the fact that she
wasn't referred to as an elemental
spirit
makes me think that she might be
something different what do you guys
think
is dryad the elemental spirit of the
earth
or is she something else what role do
you think that she is going to play
in the rest of the story let me know
down below so
even before they arrived in elysia dryad
knew that the heart kingdom gang was
coming
and she also knows that the door to the
afterlife the tree of cliffhoth
is about to open and of course because
she knows that
she also knows that if a bunch of devils
invade
this world then that would be very bad
news for elysia
and for that reason dryad decides to
work together with the heart kingdom
gang
and to help them out dryad ends up
teaching everyone
how to use ultimate magic an overpowered
secret technique that is normally used
exclusively by the elves
this is because the human body is just
too weak to channel all of that mana
effectively
however because the heart kingdom gang
has the ability to channel the mana of
nature
because of the techniques that they
learned inside the heart
kingdom dryad believes that she can
actually teach them to use the ultimate
magic technique
even though they are not elves if they
only had access to their own
mana these humans would never be able to
use
that technique but because they now also
have access to the mana of nature
with dryad's help they will be able to
transcend
the true magic of the heart kingdom and
they will be able to use the
even stronger ultimate magic of the
elf tribe back in the present the heart
kingdom gang
begins using their true magic to
annihilate those lower tier devils who
were pouring out of the tree of
cliffhoth and invading the spade kingdom
capital
i mean these guys are basically just npc
devils so they were used as a way for
the heart kingdom gang to demonstrate
the extent of their cool new powers
sally is especially excited about true
magic's ability to take out enemies
while sparing
all their allies on the battlefield and
she hopes that she will get to research
this magic at
some point in the future but even though
the low tier devils can be taken out
relatively easily using true magic new
middle tier devils suddenly appear
behind
the low tier ones it is clear from the
get-go that these
mid-tier devils are far stronger than
the devils who had come before them
so the heart kingdom gang are now going
to have to rethink
their combat strategy and because
this is a highly sophisticated channel
we are definitely not going to mention
the fact that one of the mintier devils
is a tentacle devil waifu nope
no one will be talking about the
tentacle devil waifu not here in the
video
and definitely not in the comments of
this video but anyway moving on
back in elysia dryad had warned the
heart kingdom gang that while they
should be able to take out the lower
tier devils without too much trouble
the mid-tier devils and above are a
different story
that means that everyone has to be
extremely careful from this
point forward midi tier devils are in a
completely different league when
compared to the low tier devils
so this is going to get much more
dangerous from this point on
but our boy luck voltea is not afraid
in fact he sees this as the perfect
opportunity to test out his newly
acquired
ultimate magic the mid-tier devils are
acting pretty cocky and they're actually
goading the humans to come play with
them but
they quickly change their tune after
luck absolutely smashes them
using his ultimate magic technique
luck looks absolutely awesome
while using this new technique and he
moves so fast that the devils
can't even see him they never even saw
him coming
wow what an incredible power and i can't
wait to see
more of this the chapter then switches
focus to what's going on
inside the spade kingdom palace so we're
not 100 sure if all of those
mid-tier devils got destroyed by lux
attack
or if more work would need to be done to
take them all out
personally i'm hoping that tentacle
devil waifu survives
but it definitely looked like luck was
able to take them all down
on his own and in record time and if
we're being real that is absolutely
crazy if just one member of the heart
kingdom gang can take out a bunch of
mid-tier devils with a single ultimate
magic attack
then we can only imagine what will
happen when everyone begins to use their
ultimate magic techniques at the same
time
this is without a doubt a massive power
up for
the entire heart kingdom gang but you
know what
they are going to need it all of these
devils that we've been seeing so far
at least the ones outside of the palace
are absolute
child's play compared to the high tier
devils like lilith nama
lucifer magikola and so on it's gonna
take
all of their ultimate magic and much
much more to stand up to those
strongest devils so yes these are major
power ups and i can't wait to see all of
them in action
but with that said we shouldn't make the
mistake of thinking that this ultimate
magic technique alone will be enough to
defeat
the strongest devils those guys are on a
whole other level so this fight
is far from over meanwhile the spade
kingdom castle is being engulfed by both
burning and freezing attacks attacks
which appear to be coming from
lilith and nama and what's more
these burning and freezing attacks
appear to have taken out
knocked the final panel of the chapter
shows a severely
injured knock he's pretty much
immobilized because the two devils have
used their magic to impale his body
in multiple places and beyond that what
made me even more worried was the fact
that noct's head
is facing downwards as if he has lost
consciousness
or worse and so just as things were
beginning to look good for our heroes on
the outside of the palace
we are now left worrying about knocked
as his life clearly hangs
in the balance his life is now in direct
and immediate danger and who knows what
can happen
in the next chapter now do i think that
noct
is dead already no i think he's still
alive
but i also think that noct could lose
his life by the end of this
arc as i mentioned in previous videos
the stakes are extremely high
in this epic final showdown against the
dark triad and all of those
devils and when facing such overpowered
devil villains it is totally possible
that someone important
might die in fact it's actually quite
likely
in my opinion that some big deaths will
be happening before this arc is through
since noct is the black bull member who
was introduced
last and whom we've only met a little
while ago
tabitha might believe that his death
wouldn't upset fans as much as the death
of another black
bull so with that in mind tabitha might
kill off knocked
at some point in the near future this is
especially plausible now that nacht has
already helped asta with his devil union
training
so he's already fulfilled that important
aspect of his role
in the story unfortunately it is totally
possible that tabatha might feel that
knocked has already served his purpose
for the story
and now might be a good time to kill him
off
even though killing knocked off would
definitely underscore the importance
and seriousness of this situation i
personally still hope that noct won't
die
because we only just met him and i want
to know more about him
especially after all the time we as fans
spent wondering about who is the black
bull's vice captain and where has he
been
for this whole time but i have to accept
that knox's death is definitely a
possibility
as is the death of many other important
characters
obviously astan noel yuno and a few
other main characters
are safe let's be real but a recently
introduced character like
knocked is definitely not safe in my
opinion
but let me know what you guys think are
we about to witness
some major character deaths and maybe
even the death of knocked
the final panel of this chapter
certainly suggests that knocked
is in big trouble but he's probably just
injured since this is a battle shonen
and a character like knocked wouldn't
just be killed
off screen with that said though do you
guys think that knocked will die
during this arc and if not him then who
else do you think
could die before this epic battle ends
also what did you think about ultimate
magic
did you like this insane technique and
do you think that it stands a chance
against the high tier devils like
lucifer
or do you think that lucifer is still
too strong for even the strongest users
of ultimate magic definitely share your
thoughts down in the comments below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more black clover content right
here on the channel
please remember to leave a like it only
takes a second but it helps
a lot and if you're new to anime out pro
or maybe you haven't subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications if you don't want to
miss our videos in the future
you have to go through the trouble of
subscribing hitting that bell
and then selecting the option that says
all i know it's annoying but if you
don't do it you're going to miss a ton
of our videos even if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
a big thank you to all of our anime
outpour patrons for making videos like
this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma
disciple of lord twego himself
and i can't forget all of our the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above
all other clans including ingrata
the world a quiet respect pate heffa
liam thompson
algertal dr cortman johnny boy draws
emperor otaku spidey life canal baked
buddhist and tungsten tarkis
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh
steelers on hell crews anatoly kazatsky
joe stanton very gucci jessica kaylafond
rathune de ora
alicia octor bonnie parks hinokami and
water the red-haired raven joanne garcia
jack watches anime fat boy games ted no
ted
deadly saint matthew cruz and anthony
schreiber
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value for you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patreon exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you